the cross test between scp-682 and  SCP-173 with high Precision Blades was a  complete disaster organized by Dr  Shenron the two iconic monsters were  brought into a test chamber and the  blades were deployed cutting both of  them into pieces two d-classes were sent  in when the vacuum system failed and  were killed by scp-682's Blobs of Flesh  and the newly reformed SCP-173 at this  point the battle began and 173 attacked  the different Blobs of 682 flash some  blobs fought back While others reformed  into a smaller version of 682 which  stared at 173 just like in the original  test a sniper shot out the eyes of this  smaller 682 leading 173 to snap its neck  it then regenerated and stared at 173  for 17 hours before the test was finally  ended when 173 was taken back to its  cell there was a power failure in the  hallway leading to a site-wide  Containment Breach and many deaths